i want you to work on your self-belief
and confidence
write out
what kind of confidence you will need to
have to achieve that goal
what beliefs do you need to believe to
achieve that goal you know someone said
to michael jordan you're so lucky that i
know
the more i train
the luckier i become
because you make your own luck
write out your beliefs write out the
confidence you will give to yourself
because you can fill yourself up with
confidence you were born with it you
haven't lost it you just buried it under
limiting beliefs you can remove those
let's go to another page and this is
really important
you
are worth it you might go look that's
just the same as the other page not
quite
and even if it was i want you to exhaust
yourself with writing you may just say
i've only written three lines it's fine
but tomorrow you might think of another
one and come back why are you worth it
why do you deserve this goal what makes
you worth it why do you know you're
worth it
how do you know you are worth it
and if you don't know how you going to
know that you are worth it
you must believe your worth that you
must know you're worth it when you know
it
the world will join you in knowing it
too
remember pause the video
please don't try and keep up with me
this is serious i want to pause
write
unpause write more i want you to do this
most people
listen to these tutorials but this is
not something to listen to somebody
participate in
do it with me i'm doing this for you i
want you to have phenomenal success
and while you're writing i'm going to
tell you something you probably already
know there were many studies in the 50s
where they took
a group of graduates and said how many
of you have goals
and how many of you write them down
amazingly i think this is not word for
word so please don't quote me but i
pretty much know this i believe three
percent of that graduating year had
goals and
wrote them out a higher percentage had
goals and didn't write them out and
another group had no goals at all
they went back 20 years later 30 years
later
the wealth of the 3 percent who had
goals and wrote that was worth more
than the other 97 combined not only did
they have monetary goals that they'd
reached
they had better relationships better
health and all of this was attributed
right back to one thing
they had goals
they wrote them out
and they wrote out how to achieve them
why to achieve what it would feel like
when they achieved them who would
benefit when they achieved them
they didn't probably do all of that but
that's what i make my clients do
and if you do it
you know that you can have that success
because that test has been done more
than once it was done again
in the 1980s it was done again in the
1990s
and we're doing it today
write out your goals write out your why
write out your reasons write out what
you are going to learn
the new things you're going to learn if
you're going to be a writer you're going
to be a speaker if you're going to have
your own business you better learn
accountancy and so on and so on if
you're going to sell
you need to learn how to speak or if you
want to be a great anything
you need to learn marketing
i train people into be being phenomenal
therapists i tell them the truth look
it doesn't matter how amazing you are if
nobody knows
where you are the biggest message i want
to get across when it comes to the law
of attraction is that it requires
effort it requires some type of action
that's why in the word attraction you
see action in the word you don't just
get to write down something on a piece
of paper or have a vision board or you
know map something out or cut out photos
and and look at it in front of you every
single day or write down things on a
piece of paper and think hard about it
for a few minutes and then expect
everything in your life to change and to
be this magnet of opportunities to have
everyone that you want in your life
attracted to you
money good health opportunities with
your career it's not gonna happen
overnight like that
and i wish it did but it's not that easy
so there are some beliefs and actions
that we need to take
place in order for it to work and that's
what we're going to do by diving into
today so the first thing you want to
think about is switching from negativity
to positivity
so many people get caught up in focusing
on what they don't want to happen in
their future and i want to talk about
this a little bit towards the end of
this video on how to focus on
some of the negative things that could
happen but really focusing on the
positive for the main part of your life
we'll talk about that towards the end
because this is an important distinction
but they start living almost in constant
fear of what could go wrong and what
won't work out and when we come from
this place of well i don't know if i put
myself out there you know it's not gonna
work out and then i'm gonna get made fun
of and then people i'm gonna be
embarrassed and i'm gonna be stressed
and no one's gonna love me and then we
go in this rabbit hole and this
kind of cycle of fear and anxiety and
that is not
how you attract good things in your life
you can't
start from your way of being of
negativity and fear and expect to
attract beautiful things in your life
so we we need to eliminate the negative
self-talk and an environment that's easy
to get stuck in sometimes can be the
negative self-talk and there's so much
negativity in the world and if you don't
actively work to shift your focus to
shift your thoughts and your mind that
negativity will consume you and that's
where the law of attraction comes in now
for me it's about focusing less
on what i don't want to happen in the
future and actually focus on what i do
want and again i think a lot of people
focus on what they don't want too much
and you start to attract the things
you're thinking about i don't want this
i don't want that those things start to
come to you you start to see them
it's like the exalt example if someone
says you know don't think of a pink
elephant you start to see it and you
start to imagine it you say well i don't
want to be poor you start to feel it you
start to imagine it and you start to
have anxiety around it so you want to
really think about the positive things
in your life you want to think about
what do i want to attract who do i want
to become what do i want to overcome so
for example if you're becoming a
negative person you're more likely to
attract
more negative people rather than
positive ones because positive people
won't want to be around you you know
negativity keeps company and so does
positivity when you start to see other
positive people that are like you you
say i want to hang out with those people
those people are going to continue to
lift me up i can lift them up it's a
good cycle but the negative stuff you
start to attract when you talk about
gossip and you talk about bad news when
you talk about comparison and judgment
and anxiety and stress
that feeds in a community of other
people that speak in the same language
so you want to shift your language and
start thinking more positively and if
you feel like you aren't deserving of a
loving relationship a loving partner
you're most likely going to attract the
wrong type of people in your life and if
you're focusing on how much money you
don't have in your life right now or how
your business could fail
you're not going to be able to focus
your energy on the right clients or the
products that will take your business to
the next level or the skills you need to
develop to help you grow now your
thoughts dictate your actions and where
your energy goes so you want to be
thinking about
what can i do to replace these negative
thoughts the anxiousness of the fear how
can i replace it so my energy can go in
a more positive direction and again
where you put your energy into is what
you attract
so if you're thinking energy thoughts
all day long you're probably going to
attract that if you're thinking
gratitude and positive thoughts you'll
start to see that show up differently so
how can we put the law of attraction
into practice now let's go back to our
examples and apply a new way of thinking
if you're caught and thinking negatively
about the world and about yourself this
is so important
what would change inside of you if you
looked around
and you wrote down five things that
you're grateful for about the world now
this for me
is part of the secret to the law of
attraction it's the foundation is
gratitude it's your way of being must be
grateful in order to attract new things
there's so many things in my life that i
should not have attracted
because i didn't have the skills because
i didn't have the tools because i didn't
have the education because i didn't have
the money because i didn't have the
resources
so many things that i shouldn't have
attracted but because i had the
foundation of gratitude
passion joy curiosity those things
started to come to me and they can come
to you as well if you come from that
place of gratitude as your foundation
so you want to think about what are
these things that are important to me in
my life you know it can be simple things
it could be like this cup of coffee that
i have right now it can be that i have a
roof over my head that i've got quality
friends that i'm healthy
you know that i'm walking in nature
today it doesn't have to be
some grandiose thing that's happened to
you to be grateful for i'm so grateful
for these little present moments
with people that i care about to spend
an hour on the beach to go for a walk
with a friend to have a good
conversation with someone and talk about
something that i'm going through for me
that's just as meaningful the moments in
between the big moments are just as
meaningful so write down these things or
think about these things this is
something i embed in my daily life when
i wake up i think about what i'm
grateful for when i go to sleep i i
think about and reflect on the things
i'm grateful for from that day and it's
just my way of being for as much as i
can now i'm not perfect i make mistakes
and there's some times i'm negative
but it's something that i try to really
focus on as much as possible so instead
of saying that you're not enough
that you don't deserve success what if
you looked in the mirror on a daily
basis i dare you to look in the mirror
on a daily basis and say i am enough and
i do deserve
the results that i want to create in my
life because i show up because i'm
consistent because i work hard because i
care about my work
if you looked in the mirror and you did
this consistently for 30 days and you
actually
use the word action in attraction and
you put it into practice on a daily
basis towards that growth
i'd be amazed to see what you attract
and what you manifest in your life or if
you felt like you weren't deserving of a
loving partner and just kept focusing on
the wrong people
what if you said you know what i am
deserving of a loving partner because i
care deeply about those around me and i
am worthy of feeling deeply cared about
myself
and what if you started to change your
thoughts and behaviors around yourself
say i'm not going to keep doing the
things that i've always done i'm going
to start showing up differently and love
myself not needing someone else to love
me who maybe isn't in the right mindset
and start distancing yourself from those
typical patterns that you've had in the
past and love yourself first and see
what you attract from that loving
grateful place with yourself or if you
are in a tough financial spot maybe
you're struggling financially and you've
been trying to start a business or a
side hustle
i've been there i know what this feels
like it's not fun for a long time i was
living on my sister's couch and i didn't
have much money it was really stressful
i remember this feeling of being stuck
feeling like i was never going to make
any money and when i was focusing on
that feeling of i'm never going to make
this money i feel stuck i feel trapped
when's this going to happen feeling this
anxiousness this stress around it
it was really impossible for me to think
of creative ideas it was impossible for
me to
take action because i was living in the
stress as opposed to the gratitude for
what i was having in that moment i
should have been focusing on you know
what my sister is allowing me to stay
here for free so i have some time to
learn a new skill
i made a hundred dollars this day i
should be grateful for that not a
focusing on what i'm lacking or what i
don't have but what i am creating on a
daily basis and i started to ask
different questions around this time
like how can i be of service to other
people how can i add as much value to
someone else or what are my top skill
sets that i can use
to my advantage that no one else has
like what do i have i started writing a
list of all these different skills that
i had even when i didn't think i had
many skills i still wrote down a list of
the qualities i have of the skills from
the past that maybe i could apply to
right now and when i began asking those
types of questions i started attracting
the people who needed my skill sets and
services and i finally started to make
more money than ever before because i
was thinking about serving others i was
thinking from a positive grateful
standpoint about helping others and
starting a side hustle which turned into
a business instead of thinking
negatively about not having any money or
i'm sleeping on my sister's couch and
why is it taking me so long to create
this and i'll never make anything from
this situation i started focusing on how
can i add value as much value as
possible to this one person in front of
me right now how can i serve them how
can i create for them how can i connect
someone to them that could help them
what can i do to add value and help
someone else achieve their goals because
i think as zig ziglar said if you want
to accomplish all of your goals help
other people accomplish their goals and
that's what i started focusing on not
what i'm lacking but how can i give and
how can i add value to other people when
you focus outward on service you start
to really attract some incredible things
in your life it's unbelievable the
ripple effect the domino effect one
person helping another person how it
comes back around to you if the sun is
energy
and you sit outside
and uh you know you're enjoying the sun
and it's nice and warm
if you sit long enough
the concentration of energy on your face
may cause a little bit of a tan right so
it's gonna cause your skin to get tanned
agreed so the energy is having an effect
the energy that's 93 million miles away
that's taking 8.8 minutes to reach my
face from the sun
can affect my skin right now what if
what if i took that sun and in between
the sun
and my face okay i i took that that
light
right you see you see the light if i
took that light and focused it through
the lens concentrated it to my face
could i burn a hole in my skin or if i
took one of my goal cards right it's my
gold cards right if i took the sun
right and i
and i've
used it to
magnify to increase the amplitude of the
vibration
of the energy called the sun through the
magnifying glass you know onto the paper
right could i burn a hole in the paper
by focusing that energy
general sun right is general heat but
with a little bit of focus and
concentration
right i can increase the amplitude of
the vibration of the sun now stay with
me
watch this what if i took the same sun
and instead of just focusing the sun
a little bit okay
a little bit you know between the sun
and the paper what if i reduce the
energy or increase the amplitude of
vibration so i can actually get a laser
single photon same sun but focused even
more highly
okay could i use the energy of the sun
to create a laser to burn through a
piece of steel
yes or yes
it's not a no yes or no question it's a
yes or yes answer okay
why is this important okay it's
important because the more you learn to
concentrate
okay the more you learn to concentrate
your brain the electromagnetic switching
station that can be fragmented or
focused
on your vision health goals wealth goals
relationship goals career goals the more
you can stop being distracted the more
you can concentrate the most powerful
tool
whoops
okay the most powerful electromagnetic
switching station
called your brain
right you activate that left prefrontal
cortex you activate the emotional parts
of your brain you activate the
instinctual parts of your brain the more
you learn how to focus on your precise
vision and goals and how you're going to
achieve it and then you take
inspired action daily the more you are
concentrating this molecular structure
called the human being to move towards
the goal but the more you are in
resonance with exactly what you want to
achieve so is it possible
that by learning how to do that
you can achieve your goals faster and
easier than ever before and the answer
is absolutely but you know what
everybody thinks oh i'm just going to
like hope and pray and my goals are
going to become a reality that is just
[ __ ] so stop fooling yourself okay
i hope you don't mind a little bit of
animation so
in the world that we live in this is one
of the other great laws the law
of cause and effect
okay the law of cause and effect for
every
effect there's a cause for every cause
there's an effect
so
if you are um thinking positively but
feeling negatively
that is a self-fulfilling doom loop
cause effect cause effect you have to do
okay i'm gonna type in something right
now
s-e-m-p
all right s-e-m-p i just typed the word
for you acid you've gotta get the
spiritual energy
the emotional energy the mental energy
and the physical
energy in alignment
if any one of those four things is out
of alignment
that would be like having your
dial on the radio station for classical
music or jazz or rock and roll or love
songs just a little bit off the station
our universe operates
by law and precision at the physical
level physical laws at the quantum level
quantum laws and yes there's randomness
in the quantum field
but it operates at lightning speeds
perfectly every time no exceptions see
this line
that's called the terror barrier yeah
jumping at you isn't it
and on the other side of the terror
barrier is something we call freedom
and you know
very few people get through that terror
barrier it's rather sad
freedom is available to everyone
there isn't anyone
that cannot live the way they want to
live
see
why don't they
why don't they
they don't know
and they don't even know they don't know
now i'm going to show you
why people experience buyer's remorse
when they buy something they really want
then they back away
or they go to move and they don't they
go to change jobs and they don't
they go to move to another city and they
don't lie
fear
causes them to stay where they are
there's the individual the x represents
the unknown
factor the paradigm
now there's a power flowing into this
individual's mind and they can make
anything out of what they want remember
we said we had the ability to choose
what do they choose they choose thoughts
that are in harmony with the paradigm
now here's an important point
the paradigm controls the vibration of
this thing we call our body our body is
a molecular instrument that's really
what it is it's a massive molecules and
a very high speed of vibration
the vibration that the body's in on a
conscious level we call feeling
when a person says they feel this way or
they feel that way what they're really
doing is describing the vibration
they're in
now
they choose thoughts
that harmonize with the vibration
they're in so they feel comfortable they
may not like the results but they're
comfortable
now let's move ahead let's take a look
here those people are getting x type
results and they don't like it
do you know what the problem with them
they're in bondage these people are
locked up
you know
paradigm is like keeping a person in a
prison
only there's no locks on the door they
can open the prison and walk out into
freedom anytime they want and they don't
they keep getting the same results over
and over and over again they're in
bondage
now let's go ahead here's the same
person
x type conditioning x type vibration
the power is flowing into them
and for some strange reason from left
field boom in comes a y type idea what
is the y-type idea the y-type idea
represents anything that you might want
to do that you're not doing
it might be moved to another city change
jobs
sell the house buy the farm whatever it
may be
ask the little girl for the date
ask the guy to go to lunch
go make the sale
buy what you want
go where you want to go that's the y
idea
but as long as the y idea is just in the
conscious mind it's just going to be an
intellectual exercise it's never going
to happen
so how do we make it happen
well
that's when everything goes haywire here
we are here same person okay the power
flows in
and what do they do they got the y type
idea
now for some strange reason they know
that they've got to get emotionally
involved that they're going to act on
that idea they don't understand what's
going to happen but clearly understand
this
your central nervous system is the most
complex electrical system in the
universe
the central nervous system
is mind-boggling it would make the
electrical system in a super computer
look like a toy now the second you take
the idea from your intellect and impress
it upon the subject of mind that's when
all hell breaks loose
because the body moves in to a next xy
vibration
it's not in the x vibration not the one
that we're comfortable with may not like
the results but we're comfortable
no on a conscious level everything's
going crazy on a conscious level we
experience doubt the doubt turns into an
emotion called fear and that fear is
expressed through the body as anxiety
see that person is getting emotionally
involved to move ahead do you know what
happens they hit that terror barrier and
they bounce off it and right back into
bondage
and they're so relieved to get back
there
they're back where they're comfortable
they've canceled the sale
they've decided not to move
they're going to stay in the job that
they don't like
at least they're comfortable
now that's not a very good way to live
and you know something that's something
everybody experiences if they're going
to grow you're going to hit that terror
barrier
see the terror barrier is going beyond
where you're at going to a new level i'm
going to tell you something when i set a
goal if if if it doesn't scare and
excite me at the same time i know i'm
going in the wrong direction
now i also understand
that my paradigm is going to try and get
me to bounce back to where i was it
doesn't want me to move ahead
i don't want to live there
i lived there for the first 26 years of
my life and for the last 50 i've had a
phenomenal life and it just keeps
getting better and i want you to do the
same thing understand what i've just
said i'm going to back this up
they got emotionally involved in the y
idea
that moved their body into a different
vibration on a conscious level they're
experiencing some crazy stuff they start
to doubt their ability will never be
able to pay for it they experience fear
the fear expresses itself as anxiety
and bang you bounce off that terror
barrier and you're right back
oh i might not be earning my chair but i
know what it is
i
i would love to move there but i'm
comfortable here i think i'll just stay
here these people are acting like they
have a contract to live forever and they
don't do you know what to do say i'm
going to get rid of all that i
understand it's there but i don't want
any part of it and i'm going to go
crashing right through that terror
barrier
now does that get rid of the x energy no
that's energy
is still there
you see but at least you're over into
freedom you made the move you did it and
if you continue to feed the right
information into your mind keep feeding
that y idea keep getting emotionally
involved in the y idea you're there
you're on the road
keep doing that you're going to find
that the paradigm is going to change and
it'll just all go away
and you know where you're living
in freedom you're living where you want
to live
fire's remorse
is when you cancel the sale
buyer's remorse is when you stop just
before you buy what you really want
before you go for the thing that's going
to change your life and you know it
it's not moving to the other city it's
not starting the business of your dreams
it's not stepping out and betting on
yourself
that's a terror barrier that's causing
that
and if you don't learn to go through the
terror barrier i'm going to tell you
something you're going to stay right
where you are
for the rest of your days
that's not a good place to be
what did joseph campbell say
so true
the cave you fear to enter
holds the treasure
you seek someone who has some faith
in a god or in a temple or whatever
who is how simple-minded faith works
only for those people who are
simple-minded thinking people people who
are too much thinking for them it never
works
a childlike person
who has a simple faith
in his god or his temple or whatever
he goes to the temple and says shiva i
want a house i don't know how you must
make it for me
now in his mind there are no negative
thoughts will it happen will it not
happen is it possible is it not possible
these things are completely removed by
the simple act of faith
now he believes shiva will do it for him
and it will happen
so is she going to come and build your
house no i want you to understand god
will not lift his little finger for you
what you refer to as god
is the source of creation
as a creator
he's done a phenomenal job there's no
question about it could you think of a
better creation than this
is it
in anybody's imagination to think
anything better than what is there right
now
so as a creator he has done his job
wonderfully well
but
if you want life to happen the way you
want it because right now the very crux
of your happiness and your well-being is
this
if at all if you're unhappy
the only and only reason why you're
unhappy is
life is not happening the way you think
it should happen
that's all it is
so if life is not happening the way you
think it should happen you're unhappy if
life happens the way you think it should
happen you're happy it's as simple as
that
the reason why you are not chasing your
big dream is because you are afraid that
it's going to fail
you're afraid that it's not going to
work and what people will say about you
and what you will think about yourself
but what's the alternative it's sitting
on your idea for years never taking your
shot because you're afraid and living
the rest of your life in regret knowing
that you had an opportunity but were too
afraid to take it the way to not have
regrets is to be always taking action to
as soon as you get an idea go do
something about it i had a great podcast
with my friend mark draker a couple
weeks ago a month ago or so
where
he was asking me about regret and i used
to always tell this story of
imagine you have a hangnail how much
that hurts and it's all you can think
about when you have a hangnail but if
somebody punches you in the arm you
don't feel the hangnail anymore because
this hurts more right you focus on what
hurts more and suddenly this one doesn't
hurt as much that's how i would use
regret i would always think about
whatever pain that i'm in right now this
thing that i want to do but i'm afraid i
would imagine that this thing is going
to be the best thing of all time that
this video i'm going to make this speech
i'm going to give this clan i'm going to
make is going to be the best of all time
and if i don't do it i'm going to regret
it for the rest of my life for decades
i'm going to regret not taking action
and so
the pain of doing the thing is the hang
nail and the future pain of regret for
decades is the punch to the arm and so
it inflicts so much pain on me that then
i have to go off and do that thing and i
use that for
over a decade
over a decade that's the lens through
which i made decisions and saw the world
but for the past two years i haven't
done that at all i haven't talked about
it i haven't
done it for myself because i talk about
the things that i live
and i'm thinking why why don't i do that
anymore why don't i
use future regret to fuel me
and i found this because i'm always
taking action because as soon as i get
an idea i do something and so i don't
judge the idea i don't say why me i
don't ponder on the idea i don't i don't
just default to strategizing and
thinking i don't think why did i come up
with this why am i thinking about this i
just do it you get an idea you go off
and do it and that's been my mindset for
the past year and a half two years and
as a result
the breakthrough was
you don't live with regret
if you're always taking action on the
ideas that you have you don't live with
regret you might regret some of the
things you end up doing but most of the
things that you regret and other things
done as the actions undone
not undone not taken the action is not
taken you don't regret the things that
you did you get the things that you
didn't do that's most people right there
may be a couple things that you regret
that you did but for the most part it's
the things that you are too afraid to do
that you regret for the rest of your
life and so if you're constantly doing
if you're constantly taking action if
you're always jumping then you don't
have regrets
and it's been an interesting way that i
now see the world and hopefully you can
learn from as soon as you get an idea
you go off and you do something you do
that you won't have any regrets
newtonian world is all about the
predictable it's all about predicting
the future but the quantum model of
reality is is about causing an effect
the moment you start feeling abundant
and worthy you are generating wealth the
moment you're empowered and feel it
you're beginning to step towards your
success
the moment you start feeling whole
your healing begins and when you love
yourself and you love all of life you'll
create an equal and now you're causing
an effect
and i think that's the the difference
between living as a victim
in your world saying i am this way
because of this person or that thing or
this experience they made me think and
feel this way
when you switch that around you become a
creator of your world and you start
saying my thinking and my feeling is
changing an outcome in my life and now
that's a whole different game and we
start believing more that we're creators
of reality how do we then go from that
like mechanistically
to begin this visualization process of
something that's empowering it's me in a
different state it's my future self is
it meditation is it
what does that look like if you're not
being defined by a vision of the future
then you're left with the old memories
of the past and you will be predictable
in your life
and if you wake up in the morning and
you're not being defined by a vision in
the future as you see the same people
and you go to the same places and you do
the exact same thing at the exact same
time
it's no longer that your personality is
creating your personal reality now your
personal reality is affecting or
creating your personality your
environment is really controlling how
you think and feel unconsciously because
every person everything every place
every experience has a neurological
network in your brain
every experience that you have with
every person produces an emotion so some
people will use their boss to reaffirm
their addiction to judgment they'll use
their enemy to reaffirm their addiction
to hatred they'll use their friends to
reaffirm their addiction to suffering so
now they need the outer world to feel
something
so
to change then
is to be greater than your environment
to be greater than the conditions in
your world in the environment is that
seductive
so then
why is meditation the tool well
let's sit down let's close our eyes
let's disconnect
from your outer environment so if you're
seeing less things there's less
stimulation going to your brain if
you're playing soft music or you have
ear plugs in less sensory information
coming to your brain so you're
disconnecting from your environment if
you can sit your body down
and tell it to stay like an animal stay
right here i'm gonna feed you when we're
done you can get up and check your
emails you can do all your texts but
right now you're going to sit there and
obey me
so then
when you do that properly and you're not
eating anything or smelling anything or
tasting anything you're not up
experiencing and feeling anything
you would have to agree with me that
you're being defined by a thought right
so when the body wants to go back to its
emotional past
and you become aware that your attention
is on that emotion and where you place
your attention is where you place your
energy you're siphoning your energy out
of the present moment into the past and
you become aware of that
and you settle your body back down in
the present moment because it's saying
well it's eight o'clock you normally get
upset because you're in traffic around
this time and here you are sitting and
we're used to feeling anger and you're
off schedule oh it's 11 o'clock and
usually check your emails and judge
everybody well the body's looking for
that that predictable chemical state
every time you become aware that you're
doing that and your body is craving
those emotions
and you settle it back down into the
present moment you're telling the body
it's no longer the mind that you're the
mind and now your will
is getting greater than the program and
if you keep doing this over and over
again over and over again over and over
again just like training a stallion
or a dog it's just gonna say
i'm gonna sit and the moment that
happens when the body's no longer the
mind when it finally surrenders
there's a liberation of energy
we go from particle to wave from matter
to energy and we free ourselves from the
chains of those emotions that keep us in
the in the familiar past and we've seen
this
thousands of times in fact we can
actually predict it now when we stop
expecting things to be the way that we
think they should be when we stop
forcing outcomes and when we start
allowing what is of the highest good to
be our only agenda our only intention
that's when the universe truly has our
back that's when we can
live what it means to surrender true
surrender comes when we stop
praying for what we think we need and we
start
connecting and grounding in what could
possibly be of the highest
good for all
and when we stop praying for what we
think we need and we start allowing what
is of the highest good for all so true
manifesting is about receiving what is
of the highest good for all and it
begins not just with what well how will
i get what is of the highest good but
how can i be open to what is of the
highest good how can i open up my
consciousness to release what i think i
need and get grounded in what is
possible and what is of the highest good
not just for me and my agenda but the
highest good for all that's the message
so you're doing everything right in that
you're
open to a spiritual practice you're
willing to grow you're showing up for
your practice you're reading books
you're doing the work you're here on
dear gabby you're showing up you're
showing up you're showing up you're
doing a lot of doing though and you're
also doing a lot of expecting and so a
lot of doing and a lot of expecting are
two major blocks to your ability to
attract what it is that you want into
your life and so it's the doing doing
doing that actually creates sort of a
manic manifesting vibration which is how
do i get that how do what am i what do i
do next got to do this thing next got to
do this thing next and that lacks the
belief system that i can be still and i
can allow
that's number one number two being in
the expectation of what you think things
should be is another block to your
manifesting power and your super
attractor power which is what i call it
because your expectations are limiting
the possibilities your expectations are
limiting the highest good as this card
says so when we start to pray for what
is of the highest good rather than
intend and pray for what we think we
need that's when the universe can
conspire with what it is that is of the
highest good for all
so ultimately what's happening is all
the doing doing doing is energetically
blocking
and all the expecting expecting
expecting is blocking the manifestation
as well because when you're in this
tunnel vision of expectation it should
be this way i should be further along i
shouldn't be here what's happening is
you're missing the opportunity to
recognize where you are how great things
are in this moment what is possible in
this moment the creative possibility in
this moment the exciting potential in
this moment you're blocking it blocking
it blocking it blocking it blocking it
blocking it
i want you to sit on your ass
i want you to stop doing doing doing
i want you to
start being
being
being which is what you also said you're
actually dear gabbying yourself
you said i want to embody the feeling i
want to embody the emotion
the being
is a presence it's an energy it's a
state
it's not an action
true manifesting does require
us to show up for our desires you got to
pick up the phone and then call the job
interview and you have to ask for the
date and you have to to do whatever it
is that you want to create but
ultimately
the greatest source of power that we
have to attract what we want is how we
feel everyone wants to manifest things
fast we are in a society where
everything can happen instantly remember
the old days where you had to go to a
library to learn about something or
research about something anything you
were curious about you had to go to the
library and actually look it up and now
we can literally have the answer to any
question that pops into our mind within
30 seconds or less through a smartphone
times have changed a lot we expect
things immediate and fast and of course
the same applies to manifesting we think
of something we want we ask for it we
hold the space we follow the steps and
then we want it right now and i totally
get it that's normal based on the way
we're programmed in society it's the
instant gratification that we are
programmed to expect
but when it comes to manifesting
time really is an illusion
because everything you desire is already
here and it already exists
you just have to align with it and
attract it
typically what i see with a lot of
clients and even personal friends is
that they follow a few steps and they
think they did everything correctly but
then when it doesn't show up right away
or by the deadline that they set they
panic or get frustrated or just give up
but the thing about manifesting is that
the magic truly happens when it looks
like that thing isn't happening and
isn't gonna show up and then the very
last second it shows up anyway there is
this beauty and power and magic in
creation so let's get into this powerful
manifesting hack that i swear by but
also let me be clear it's not up to you
to control the timing or force anything
to happen based on what you think is
best
it's more about allowing
but this hack will make your
manifestation show up much more quickly
than if you hadn't used this so here it
goes i always say what you expect is
what you attract
because expectations are a fundamental
force in what you
experience think about all of the
expectations you have on a daily basis
you expect to wake up
maybe at a certain time maybe not
you expect to have coffee or tea or eat
breakfast or not you expect to maybe go
to work or you have a morning workout
you expect to eat at a certain time be
home at a certain time go to bed at a
certain time you expect to see certain
people talk to certain people experience
certain things throughout your day and
in turn that creates your reality these
are all expectations that you've created
based on your routine
but imagine if you expected the thing
that you want as being real what if you
were able to shift into a certain
energetic frequency to attract much
quicker this is what i want to show you
how to do right now
so here's how it all works and what to
do
the way this hack works is by shifting
energies and changing your expectations
because what you expect is what you
attract i'll be saying this a lot
because i have to drive this one home
it's so important what you expect is
what you attract so in order to do this
manifesting hack you're going to have to
grab a paper and pen and let's get
started the first thing you're going to
do is write down the words i am certain
followed by whatever it is that you
intend to manifest and i mean actually
write it don't just type this on your
computer don't just say this in your
mind in order for this manifesting hack
to truly work you have to write it down
on paper so you're going to write down
the words i am certain and then insert
the thing that you intend to manifest
but do it in present tense it is so
important that you actually write this
because there is power and scientific
proof that writing things down helps
solidify in your mind so don't skip this
step get off your chair go get that
paper and pen and actually write the
words i am certain followed by the
intention of what you want and make sure
you write this in present tense that's
extremely important to note so for
example i am certain that i have blank i
am certain that blank is mine i am
certain that i have more money than i
know what to do with i am certain that i
have the most amazing supportive loving
partner i am certain that this is mine
so you write down the words i am certain
followed by a statement of the thing
that you intend to manifest in present
tense as if it's already here and that
you're certain of it and after you write
it down i want you to sit in the feeling
and the energy of being certain that
it's yours for as long as you need
and this feeling of certainty can feel
different for each person maybe it just
feels like this wave of comfort and
relief that you are so certain of it
that you don't have to worry about when
and how just feel the feelings of being
100 totally certain that it's going to
happen and it's so obvious that you
can't imagine it not happening just like
how you were totally certain of the
things that you expect throughout your
day explore the feeling of certainty
that this thing will for sure happen no
matter what what does that feel like to
you
and i know that you probably want an
exact amount of time to sit in this
feeling but the amount of time that you
need is different for each and every
person it's based on your thoughts and
your beliefs and your resistance about
this thing that you want it'll determine
how long you need to stay in this
feeling so i can't give you an exact
answer of like 10 minutes 20 minutes an
hour
do what feels best for you you will know
how long to do it based on how you feel
so trust that and trust yourself when
you use this manifesting hack you are
tapping into the same energetic
frequency of the thing that you want and
therefore you are attracting it much
more quickly
the feeling of certainty has a really
powerful energetic force behind it
because it shapes your physical reality
so if you are putting out the energy of
certainty that you know and expect it
fully that it will show up it sets forth
an activation of your desire did you
know that there are actually six
principles that when used in a specific
order create an activation for your
desire to show up in your reality yes
this is really how it works and it
really is that simple and i've developed
an entire system that shows you exactly
what to do when to do it and how inside
of the manifesting activation system
this system works for each and
everything that you intend to manifest
using a combination of quantum physics
energy work subconscious programming and
mindset work designed to clear
resistance shift your energy and create
new beliefs and expectations about what
you get to have it's truly
groundbreaking and the results are
incredible because you made it this far
in a video i want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you are different you are
special believe nation you made it here
all the way to the end and i love you so
it's a special celebration if you put a
hashtag believe down in the comments
below on this video i will showcase you
and celebrate you somewhere on the
screen in a future video because you are
awesome if you want to activate the law
of attraction check the video right
there next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there everybody at least kind of in the
mass market
what you're trained to think about when
you think about manifesting is vision
boards and when you hear the word vision
boards you think about the big stuff